bier und blasmusik waren natürlich
pflicht beim auftritt des designierten
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten markus
söder beim politischen aschermittwoch
der csu in passau
in seiner rede vor rund 4000 zuhörern
forderte söder die unionsparteien auf
ihren politischen standort grundlegend
zu überdenken
die union müsse wlan deutlich machen
dass die ja die keine ersatz union und
nicht bürgerlich sei das bedeutet keinen
rechtsruck sondern die rückkehr zur
alten glaubwürdigkeit die union liebe
freunde darf sich nicht nur in der mitte
drängen
die union darf nicht dauernd nur noch
links spielen und die union darf nicht
nur durchregieren um jeden preis für
mich ist klar liebe freunde wir müssen
eine sagen wir sind für die bürgerliche
mitte da aber wir wollen auch die
demokratische rechte wieder bei uns
vereinen liebe freunde
großen applaus erhielt sie dafür seine
forderung nach konsequenteren
abschiebungen abgelehnte asylbewerber
nach wie vor sei deutschland das einzige
land der welt das man ohne pass hinein
aber nicht mehr hinaus komme sagte der
csu politiker ironisch
wir unser land nicht will der muss auch
nicht hier bleiben und wer uns am land
gewalttätiges liebe freunde wer muss am
ende die konsequenz des rechtsstaates
spüren und rom ist klar wer nicht
anerkannt ist der gewalttätiges der muss
wieder zurück in seine heimat und das
müssen wir auch endlich umsetzen für
alle miteinander leben
söder schwor die csu auf die
landtagswahl im oktober ein
im gegensatz zu anderen parteien habe
die csu ihre führungs krise überwunden
sagte söder und dankte dem parteichef
entscheidenden ministerpräsidenten horst
seehofer für so wörtlich 10
hervorragende jahre
[Applaus]